I wasn't like no scholar in high school
didn't go to college so this has got to
be off straight gut instinct and what I
know what's up folks ron killings also
known as r-truth WWE and this is my
bracket all right go get into this
bracket right now okay meaning I got
history I know all of these guys on here
these iconic legends on here gets me
keep it real with y'all Austin
Bob Backlund gotta go with on that all
right
Bob still got that chicken wing for you
though Rob left gonna take her Rock
Hogan and Rey Rey Mysterio ask me amigo
and I see my yeah Johnson and buckle
down hook my dog
I like John to know then that's my
childhood here with a book for my dog
Shawn Michaels in curtain I just
yesterday Ric Flair and Eddie
yeah
damn Eddie right now I like that okay
Bret Hart and Jericho
I just thought attire you inches Bret's
nice so I might to take that rock and
Bruno Salmons okay I like rock oh so
this is my bracket now we're getting
down to who's gonna win between these
guys but Brock is a mountain of a man
rain Booker bookie much I love you book
yeah my little book ah damn money push
book
well where's Mysterio um her tango and
Eddie so Kurt a week ago but we just
talked about Eddie I got a new t-shirt
so Eddie
Brett and rock Oh y'all didn't like that
hmm
[Music]
that's my bracket I this is my final for
Brock lesner Rey Mysterio
Eddie Guerrero and the rock hmm I wasn't
like no scholar so this has got to be
off straight gut instinct and what I
know red Mysterio versus the rock
that's my tutor go at it you know give
it to me I'm a stereo and the rock boom
I just saw all right I haven't seen
rocking a while it's really going on who
I've seen recently you know saying
that's what you should stick to that you
don't an out of sight out of mind right
but I know right I know I just um you
got a phone number all right guys you
got it
rey mysterio this is my pic this is my
bracket if you got one better let's see
let's see
show me your bracket show me your pics
show me your lineup who you got this is
mine and again set it off with available
on all digital platform go check it out
on YouTube and you can set it off
yourself